the reason Ben is here today it's a
serious topic and I'm really glad you're
doing this
tell everyone what we're talking about
Ben we're talking about a serious health
issue we're talking about prostate
cancer right and the reason we're
talking about it is you you had it I had
prostate cancer a couple years ago yeah
and this happened when you were 48 that
you got died asked I mean at first I
didn't know what was gonna happen so I
was scared you know I was scared I
didn't know you know that one thing that
it does is it just stops everything in
your life when you get a diagnosis of
cancer because you can't you can't plan
for a movie you can't know you know
because you don't know what's gonna
happen I have to get surgery I did you
did not choose Whittier your surgeon
yeah bring him in yeah definitely all
right this is dr. Ted Shafer you caught
it early right it was picked up early
and he was he's doing great
now the the decision-making about what
treatment you have is a complicated
journey there's a whole variety of what
kind of cancer you can get and then
there's what's the age of the patient
and how healthy is that patient you know
what kind of cancer did Ben have he had
an intermediate ly aggressive cancer
when I got the diagnosis and the doctor
said to be not not Ted but he but he
didn't really give me a great you know
his bedside manner wasn't great right
and you know he was talking about you
know like taking his kid to school exam
oh yeah and it's oh yeah it's cancer
yeah and you know look let me tell you
why I think it's pretty pretty pretty
sure it's survivable and I think the
continents and the impotence thing you
know you know and also he's saying all
these things I'm like wait a minute
cancer and comma continents you're
hearing it all yeah and I never I didn't
even know what the urologist was right
week and a half ago so you know it's
that that all those priorities sort of
change when you get down to it which is
I want to be alive one of the main
things I felt was I was really lucky as
I learned more about prostate cancer I
learned that you know I was someone who
had you know a case that could be
treated a lot of people who can't
because it's too late because they
discovered too late I mean you got very
yeah and that's that's why I went from
being like oh poor me I have cancer - oh
my god I'm so lucky